people uh people dm us a lot of
interesting ideas my reply to all of
them they go what do you think about
this i always reply with two things i
always say it's an amazing idea
and then i say when are you launching
i feel like i can rule the world i know
uh let's start the episode here
um all right what um i've got actually
two interesting things to tell you the
first this company reached out it's a
famous publication that you know of and
i don't want to say it out loud yet but
they want us to go to baja mexico to
ride motorcycles and film a series on
like a weekend adventures are you
interested in that uh what for like they
yeah what's what's the catch you want me
to come out here and surf and ride
motorcycles what's in it for you they
just have
uh i guess i could talk about it i
haven't asked if i could talk about it's
just like it's a
without giving too much weight they have
a just a web series that goes in like on
tv it's for web and tv they have a tv
channel and they have this whole series
where they it's all about like nine to
five workers like normal yuppy jobs and
you have adventures friday to sunday so
like what all can you do on a weekend
uh okay all right uh that seems super up
you know and kind of a while too but you
know
uh that's that's their suggestion do you
have a better idea on like a weekend
adventure it's an adventure publication
yeah i don't do motorcycles that's my
only thing i don't do motorcycles and
after kobe i also don't do helicopters
but uh i love surfing surfing is a cool
thing i suck at it but it's fun so i
would do that well
if you come up with a better idea then
then pitch it but they like it's all
paid for and everything
oh okay great yeah let's do that why not
ah look at your fitness influencer life
is already coming in handy
so you the what i wanted to talk about
was you're getting really fit too do you
and i think it's pretty inspiring
coming from an influencer like you in
the fitness world that means a lot to me
hardly but do you so do you think it's
do you have you has your body or i know
your body has changed has your brain
changed do you think in your attitude of
course that changes first right yeah the
attitude changes first the brain changes
first the body changes you know slowly
over time but yeah for sure but i um
like okay if people if i took off my
shirt you know nobody's gonna be super
impressed with me just yet
but i'm pretty impressed with me and
that's kind of
my own opinion i held in higher regard
than anyone else's so
yeah i basically i went from like
kind of like i don't know
was i would you be like he's fat would
fat was i fat i might have been fat
i didn't think of myself like a fat guy
and i'd be like what the hell i look fat
here i'm like every photo i look fat
maybe i'm just fat that's kind of what i
reached the conclusion of at that time
you were getting overweight i think that
like i think that you know there's like
a like a like a definition of obese like
you know it's a body fat percentage and
i guess if we use obese and fat yeah i
would say you're overweight but i don't
think you're overweight now
yeah so and and so now i've been
training hard for like a year i started
off doing two days a week three days a
week and i just cranked it up to five
days a week now with the trainer um it
was always supposed to be five days a
week but the days i was supposed to be
doing on my own i was you know really
half-assing it or no asking it so so i
would say on average i was doing like
three or four days a week before and now
i'm doing five or six days a week
pretty intense and i gotta say um i
don't know why you're bringing it up so
i don't know where you're going with
this but it's amazing and i can talk
about it all day because it's like the
best thing i've done all year so you
know if you're if you're
if you're listening to this and whatever
investment you're making right now in
your health i guarantee you that if you
upped that investment you would only
thank yourself and uh that's kind of
where i'm coming from here is like yeah
i'm i'm super happy with making this
shift and it's totally great
i have this the reason i was bringing
this up is i had this friend who is
incredibly wealthy like i would have to
imagine like 30 million dollars wealthy
and um he he was like i want to get in
shape uh what routine are you using and
i'm like that's a bad question who cares
about the routine if i was you i would
just hire a coach it'll be like 400 a
month and he was like wow that's
expensive and i'm like
dude you've got one body in one life
like i for me my fear is when i see
someone who's my age or 40 50 60 and
their body hurts and they can't walk and
they can they like struggle to sit down
on the floor or something like that i'm
like that's hell right like you're just
you're in this you're in this shitty
home that's falling apart and you can't
get out and i was like what you know you
just bought this fancy house why not
also buy a fancy body and not to like
look good naked but but like feel good
and so i was just thinking about it and
i think we talk about investing and i'm
like i think that's that's got to be the
best investment
for sure
we have we have a mutual friend i can't
say the name on here because what they
said is funny but i'll share what they
said uh so they're wealthy they're
probably like i think they have like you
know 100 million dollars you know in the
bank and um
and they said this thing they were
they're like always doing kind of like
fitnessy stuff they're not like you
wouldn't look at them and say oh yeah
this person's clearly like
you know ripped out of their mind or
they're not just like super jacked it's
not that but they live a very healthy
lifestyle and whatever wherever they go
like in their day their workout is like
a key part of their day and they don't
sacrifice it they don't get they don't
get too busy for it and so i asked him
about that and i said you know um man it
seems like you're really taking this
seriously he goes
uh yeah you know the way i look at it is
if you're rich you have no excuse to be
fat
you know what he goes look if you don't
have the money and you're all you're
just you're trying to support your
family you got to work two jobs you got
to shop at certain stores you know
mcdonald's you know you got to eat what
you can afford sometimes okay fine
like still you know not great and you
know i i want you to not be in that
situation but like i definitely
understand he goes if you're rich and
you're fat that's on you bro and uh and
that's how i feel now it's like when he
said it i was like you know that's
actually so true which is if you had all
the resources but you didn't make the
investment that matters uh that's sort
of silly right
and so uh that kind of trick that kind
of was one little seed that i got
planned in my head i'll tell you
something else that's been funny
my trainer recently um so your app
you're absolutely right what you said
which is it's not the workout routine
it's not the it's not what you do it's
not the workout program right it's not
like somebody has some secret formula
for most people it really doesn't matter
like for most people even if you just
walked 15 000 steps a day and you ate uh
only maybe 2 300 calories you're gonna
like look pretty good and you're gonna
feel probably pretty good if you're not
working out five days a week that's your
problem it has nothing to do with the
routine it doesn't matter what you did
in the routine like just start with
doing any workout and then make it
better over time and like yeah when
you're when you're sam status then the
actual routine does matter because
you know you're already at the kind of
99th percentile you're just trying to
optimize at the end and try to get
certain details to pop so yeah then your
routine matters but for most people it
doesn't matter but i'll tell you
something my trainer told me that was
counterintuitive he goes
um
we were talking about like my body has
really changed my arms have changed my
chest has changed but my stomach still
looks like the stomach of a guy who's
not super in shape like i don't have
like a six-pack that's not in the
kitchen bro
so that's what i said i was telling him
i was like oh yeah but that's all diet
right and he goes he goes you know
everybody says that he goes um they say
you can't out train your diet all the
stuff he goes and i get what they mean
he goes but i'll tell you what
intensity over diet all day
and i go what he goes intensity over
diet watch he goes don't even touch your
diet right now don't worry about your
diet uh don't be feel guilty when you
eat something don't like count every
calorie don't go way out your chicken
breast like don't do any of that [__]
all i want you to do is commit to
cranking up the intensity when we're
here in this this part of the gym so
he's like if you're like let's say zero
to ten what's the intensity of your
workout today like on average i say uh
you know it's like an eight he's like
great all we're gonna do is we're gonna
take that to a nine we're just gonna
make every workout at least a nine on
the intensity level and some days we're
gonna be hitting nine and a half and
some days we're gonna even hit a ten but
right now i just want you to focus on a
nine and he goes watch what happens and
he's been so right which is that
it was really hard to just change my
diet
but it was that much easier to just
crank up the intensity in working out
and it's not that the intensity will all
of a sudden shed my fat it's that when i
put the intensity in here diet becomes a
much easier decision because i really
like laid it all out during the workout
part and so the desire to like throw it
all away for you know this like pleasure
these chips or this whatever like it's
just not there and now i at first i
thought he's full of [__] i did not
believe him but now that now that i'm
actually trying it i just said hey let
me let me follow what you say you're my
coach
i understand what he's saying and this
is now applied to many other things in
my life so now even in business
we were i was talking to to ben about
one of our business plans and it's like
oh should we do this or this or this it
was all about the plan the how the route
you know what is the strategy
and i basically said [__] the strategy
let's just take our intensity up
you say what i said whatever strategy
we're doing let's just agree that like
right now we're probably executing any
of our strategies at a seven or eight
let's just execute any of these [__]
strategies at a nine and a half let's
just see what happens and this is just
working in all areas of my life now
because now when you put a nine nine or
a nine and a half intensity you kind of
like want to figure out the right plan
right it's like if i'm going to put in
this intensity it better be on the right
thing and your brain will solve the
which path should i choose problem in a
different way because of the intensity i
don't know if that makes sense but it's
a little no it does
the this weekend i went to f1 formula
one racing in austin it was like the hot
thing to do and i went with this guy
have you heard of uh what's it called
jungle scout you know jungle scout yeah
yeah we've talked about it it's the tool
that basically if you go on amazon and
you want to see
what products are selling how much how
much of this insta pot gets sold every
week jungle scouts this little extension
you can click on it'll tell you what how
much sales the products on amazon have
it's kind of expensive but it's a cool
product so it's a big business like um
you know if you just google it like i
you you'd have to if you could put the
pieces together that they're not far
from 100 million in recurring revenue
big business yeah and started as a
google chrome plugin which is
interesting this guy greg he's neville's
good buddy my buddy's neville so that's
how i got brought into this thing i went
with him and he's very nice very kind
easy to talk to but incredibly intense
and here's just a tiny example of when i
see this and i'm like i i like i always
see like whenever i'm around certain
people i always notice this uh when
intense people do things like this so
for example the race that just ended
some people i don't know how they got
onto it but they got onto the track i
guess they just went on and took photos
and he's like let's go and he just
starts walking over and i'm like well
there's no like gate and like everything
imagine like huge stands and then you
walk down the stands and there's like a
fence that's quite tall and he goes he's
like well let's go i'm like there's no
there's no gate and he goes no no we're
just gonna jump the fence everyone was
staring at us he just walks up without
hesitation puts his hands up there
climbs up on this fence and just hops he
goes come on let's go and i when i'm
i'm i don't like confrontation that much
i don't like doing a lot of things that
like people stare at me and i was like
what you just did like you didn't even
think twice and i've been with people
who are like really successful
entrepreneurs and they'll be like a line
and of course this is like jackass just
like a jackass move and they're like no
no we're not waiting in line we're just
gonna we're gonna walk in and we're just
gonna we're gonna do this and uh that's
like an example of that intensity have
you ever noticed like we probably have
friends that do like dude you're like
this you're an intense dude i've noticed
this from you and the line example's
perfect when we were going to do our
live show remember in miami
and the airport was just packed i don't
know why it was like six in the morning
the airport was so packed
we got there early and we were still
gonna miss our flight like the security
line was like two miles long
and we waited we waited we waited and
then you were like you just like some
switch flipped inside you that was just
like
okay we have all the reasons to like do
do like just to miss this flight
basically it's like all right we got
here early look it's just a long line
there's nothing we could do
uh you know the airport is packed it
covered just it's all
that circumstance and then i literally
we didn't even you didn't even say
anything you were just like
okay i'm gonna go and then you just left
the line so you gave up your spot which
was like a risk because we had waited
for like an hour and a half
you gave up your snuck into the the pre
you go to tsa pre-check you're not tsa
pre-check you just hand the guy your
ticket and he's like bro there's no
pre-check on this and you're like oh
yeah my my wife pre-checked it was she
we it didn't print or you're like you're
like i'm preaching
he's like look at it he's like there's
no pre-check you're like i'm pre-checked
it just didn't print
right and then he's like
your will just dominated his and then
you just got through the line
and we were like come on sean i'm still
standing there i'm like [__] if i go and
say the exact same thing that may work
and so i i was like i need to crank my
intensity up so i went and i bought
clear at that moment i just i went and
spent 200 bucks buying clear and then i
like the clear will they'll escort you
to the front of the line and like take
you through tsa and then it was like you
called me and you're like dude you got a
sprint because you were at the gate
you're like you gotta so i didn't have
my shoes on
because the security line or whatever so
i'm holding my shoes didn't have time to
put it back on i'm in my socks and i
sprinted to the gate like i've never
spent it before and i hate running so i
i hate ran my way all the way there but
it was your contagious intensity another
example
we wanted to build our podcast studio
and i was like we had kind of been
talking about it and it got to that
dangerous point that happens where you
have an idea a thing you want to do and
then you've talked about it
but you're not closing you're just
somewhere in the middle and this is
where dreams go to die and i think most
people it would just sort of like
it would either fade and you just don't
do it or you kind of half-ass it and i
remember like in a 24-hour period you
just blew up my phone you were like
dming me like
pictures of every other podcaster you're
like how about this this this just tell
me of these three which one do you want
i like number two number two and i'm
like yeah sure number two you're like
great number two okay i found the chair
on amazon actually let's drive to these
three places and like let's go pick it
up today what time are you free are you
free in 10 minutes i'll be at your house
and you came he picked me up we drove to
ikea then we drove to another furniture
spot that we drove to this bootleg spot
in oakland and then while we're at the
bootleg spot in oakland it was like not
really happening and then
and we went to another spot and then
literally the sales lady recognized your
intensity she came up to us
it was a big furniture store she comes
up she goes
you guys look like you're you guys look
like you're ready to buy i don't know
what you said she said something like
you guys look like you know what you
want and you were like yes i'm looking
for this red chair because i have a show
and i want it to pop in the thumbnail
and it's gotta look like this and she
like ran into the back and tried to find
us one and then you like got the whole
thing done and somebody meanwhile
somebody was painting the whole wall you
were like we need to paint the wall so
you like hired some guy to go paint the
wall over the weekend and by monday that
was a friday by monday the studio was
done
and i share this because
that's a level of intensity that you i
know you have that i've observed in all
of my successful friends they have this
this trait are not all i shouldn't say
some people are doing style but
very common that people who are success
have this level of intensity when they
do something massive action and um
it is contagious it's contagious to the
people around you and like the lady in
the store um
there's a there's this principle that's
kind of like this so i'm reading this
book sorry to go into tanzania here but
i'm reading this book you everybody's
heard of it you've heard of it think and
grow rich by napoleon hill have you read
love have you actually read the book
years ago but it's one of those books
that you should reread every five years
probably i should probably read it it's
pretty amazing i've had the book for
like 10 years i never even opened it
because i was kind of like i think i get
the idea um and so i actually started
reading it two nights ago and he tells a
story of this guy who
wanted to work with thomas edison he's
like this guy had a clear idea he's like
i want to work with thomas edison he
goes to notice two things
he said
he knew exactly what he wanted not just
like i want a job and a lab it's like no
i want to work with thomas edison this
guy is an amazing inventor because the
second thing is i don't want to work for
him i want to work with him as a
business partner
and so he's like you know problem is i
have no qualifications and i'm literally
not even the same city and i've never
met the guy i have no access to him i
don't know anyone who knows him but he
didn't let any of those limitations
those limitations were sort of
irrelevant to the guy so uh sure enough
he buys a train ticket he goes to where
thomas edison is he barges through the
door and he says
you know mr edison uh
i'm here to work with you like i think
you're great and i think uh you know
we'll do great work together i'm here to
work with you
and edison's like what the [__] like you
know we're not even hiring but uh like
and he said something edison has a quote
in the book which is like
even though this man had no
qualifications and i had never seen this
person he's a complete stranger
there was something about the intensity
of his presence that told me this person
has their mind set on something and
they're gonna make it happen
and that sort of reminded me of this
like common thing that's i've seen in a
lot of people and in myself in
situations which is
once you get to that level of absolute
certainty and you carry yourself people
will literally just start to respond to
you differently because they just see
this person is like on a mission they
are a man on a mission and like i may i
either need to get out of the way or i
need to get behind them and help them do
this um and that has like served me i
have one crazy story that served me well
but has that ever happened to you or
have you ever seen that yourself or
others
yeah i call it being an animal and like
paul graham or he's the one who said he
goes basically he's like a lot of people
talk about who you should hire in your
early stage startups he goes basically
the one word you want to use to describe
them is are they an animal right and do
they just get [__] done and i remember
like uh i remember talking to my friend
jake who went and worked at this company
called teespring which grew very very
quickly and i was like what's it like to
work for walker the guy who runs it and
he goes he's an animal like for example
we wanted to do this partnership and we
had been working for weeks and weeks i'm
getting in touch with these folks and he
just googled like their customer service
number and then just right there in the
meeting he goes guys watch this and he
just calls them and goes hey can i talk
to this one person uh hey this is walker
i want to make this happen what do we
got to do any like
and that's an that's a very easy example
dude i have almost the same story
when i was in college i had
i've talked a little bit about this
before but my very first business idea
was was to create the chipotle for sushi
so the same kind of fast casual model
but for sushi he done it for sandwiches
for burritos for chinese food but nobody
ever done it for sushi that was the idea
problem was i know nothing about sushi i
know nothing about the food industry i
had in fact only tried sushi for the
first time like a week before that and
that's why i even had this idea i was
like oh sushi's [__] amazing how do i
do more sushi in my life
and um and so one day i skipped class
and me and my buddy trevor we were
sitting around at our apartment and i
was like you know and trevor loves to
watch food shows like chopped iron chef
he just loved watching this food [__] i
never understood it because again i'm
not a foodie i was like why do you want
to watch other people eat food that
seems like crazy to me um but you know i
got hooked because the shows are great
obviously
and we're watching a throw down with
bobby flay and there's a sushi chef that
comes on and he's like he know obviously
he knows his [__] about sushi otherwise
he wouldn't be on the food network he
says
his qualifications were like you know
i'm in la i got my restaurant but i also
run the largest sushi academy for
training chefs so we were like oh this
guy runs the largest chef training thing
for sushi chefs and he had like this
swag to him and we had interviewed three
chefs locally
and they were all like you know think
about like a traditional japanese sushi
chef like zero kind of outward
personality
very
traditional conservative and they just
looked at us like you're like kind of
like besmirching the name of sushi like
how dare you even suggest this fast
sushi no no thank you
and so we i saw this guy and he had he
had a big personality which is why he
was on tv
and i said we need a guy like this i go
and he's and trevor is like yeah we're
going to find him i go he's right in
front of us
we need this guy and he's like okay
and so he's quiet for a second and
trevor just googles his number he's like
she turns his laptop at me he goes
here's his number
and that's like you know challenge
accepted like if your friend shows you
that it's like or you know it's like hey
that girl over there
you gotta go now you gotta go approach
that girl so i pick up the phone and i
call and i don't know why i said this i
didn't i didn't have this planned but
it's exactly what you just said the guy
walker said uh he picks somebody picks
up the phone and i'm so used to getting
the run around that i didn't expect it
to be him so i go
i need to talk to philip yee how do i
make that happen
and then he goes
so i didn't say may i please speak to
the truth which by the way that's the
right way to ask which is how do i make
this happen it's just exactly because
there's always it just came out and it
came out because i had already worked
myself into a state of intensity and i
was kind of nervous and so like i was
just in this heightened state and so
that's just what came out and he goes
this philip talk to me and i hadn't
planned what the [__] i would say after
that
and i was like oh
i said phillip
um
you've never met me but uh i'd like to
start a business with you and i know
that sounds crazy but if you give me 10
minutes um
to hear me out here out my plans i think
you'll find it really interesting it
might be something that will will extend
what you're doing in la it seems like
you have a great thing going i think
this will really uh take that and and
really blow it up
and he goes he goes what's the plan
how old am i at this time
yeah i was a senior in college so 2021
wow
and he goes what's the plan and now i
didn't have a plan so i go i go you know
what it's going to be easier for me to
email this to you what's your email
address and i bought myself two days to
like create a plan and send it to him
and later on you know so he a bunch of
stuff happens he flies out to meet us uh
we're going to school in north carolina
he flies to our college dorm basically
and meets us we fly to his i live on his
couch in
he's he like vets us but he basically
puts us through the grinder to see are
we the type of we want
which i have i don't know how the story
is going to end but at that point to me
that's a success already it's a success
already we turned this
joke of an idea
into like well it might be a funny idea
to you when i say i'm starting a sushi
restaurant but uh you know this food
network chef's on board or he's like
kind of on board he's talking to me at
least uh he's flying out here next week
so we got to prepare for that i'm not
going to class right now i got to
prepare for my chef and so
later months later when we we finally
struck a deal with him we closed it down
he's like dude you don't know how many
people he's like because celebrities eat
at my restaurant he's like you don't
know how many rich celebrities come to
me they say oh this restaurant's so
small you don't even have a liquor
license
you need to expand i'll put up the money
you need to expand he goes and i never
did business with any of them and here i
am with three [__] in college and i
decided to go into business with you and
everyone thinks i'm crazy but you know
why i go why he goes you remember what
you first said to me and i was like no
and he goes he goes you called and you
said i need to talk to philippe how do i
make that happen he goes that he's like
there was something in the way you said
it that just told me
this guy's gonna do something this guy's
gonna make something happen and he goes
he goes if you literally had not said
that phrase i don't think i would have
even ever heard you out because this is
just another one of these people who say
i want to start a restaurant with you
i'd like to partner with you blah blah
and i was like wow i didn't realize
these things make that big of a
difference and i don't think it's the
words i think it's the intensity that
will bring you to do the right thing and
say the right thing at the right time
that's great i like that how did it end
we partnered with him we go live on his
couch we train in this restaurant in l.a
and uh so you know first first day i go
there he shows me um the process for
making sushi so i don't know if have you
ever seen how a sushi chef rolls a roll
of sushi
just like the
yeah i guess so like they use that like
a piece of wood
a little bamboo there's a bamboo roller
basically but before you do any of that
right so the seaweed lays down and you
got to put the rice on it now the rice
is sticky rice uh if you've ever had
asian food you paint in these sticky
rice so how do you use your hands how do
you grab the sticky rice how do so
there's a little problem i i didn't even
realize there's a problem right i'm
sitting there watching him for an hour
so first he says just shatter me sit
here and watch me i say okay i'm
watching him and he's just making sushi
and i'm kind of getting it but i don't
even know what i'm looking for right
like any amateur when you look at
something you don't even know what
you're looking for you don't know what
the details are that matter until you
try something and this is why he was a
genius teacher one hour in he goes
the next customer walked in and i'll
tell you who it was in a second he go he
goes all right sean you're up
and he moves out of the way and i get to
go stand in that spot
wearing my stupid chef coat and i don't
know anything about anything i've just
been watching this guy i thought it
would be a long time because
traditionally in sushi if you've ever
watched like what's that giro dreams of
super hero yeah it's like
five decades the tradition is like you
spend five years just mopping the floor
you then you get to touch the veggies
then you get to touch the fish and the
last thing you ever touch is the rice
because actually sushi means vinegar
rice it's sushi is really about the rice
not about the fish so um so i didn't
expect to be doing it and so one hour
and he throws me the fire and not only
does he throw me in the fire he throws
me the fire with this guy who sits down
and i look up
and it's daryl from the office if you
ever watch the office it's daryl and
daryl's a regular there so he kind of
knew like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait daryl daryl from the office he's
the warehouse guy he's the black
warehouse oh black dude ben robinson i
think his name is
uh i don't know that's his name maybe
that's his name
something like that but daryl i know
daryl of course so so it's daryl so i'm
like oh [__] i gotta make sushi and i
make it for daryl and sushi it's like
the guy's staring at you you're two feet
away from each other like there's no
hiding in the back of the kitchen to
make it i'm making it in this guy's face
and uh and so here daryl philbin sorry
and so i so i first i just freeze i'm
just standing there and i'm looking down
at the [__] bamboo i have seaweed
bamboo and rice
and i'm like okay how did he do this and
then i'm freezing and then he walks away
i'm like [__] okay i gotta figure this
out before he comes back he comes back
up to me he hands me a shot of uh of
sake and he goes drink the [__] shot
and roll the [__] roll sean and i
so i take a shot and then i'm like okay
um
i grabbed the rice cause i'm like i
gotta spread the rice on the on the
seaweed i grabbed the rice and
immediately i know i've done something
wrong because the rice is so [__]
sticky in my hand that as i try to rub
it onto the seaweed to place it on the
seaweed it's like not gonna leave my
hand i just rip the seaweed and my hand
is like a rice glove
and he goes he's laughing and he's he
goes you know every time before i roll
the roll i dip my hand in this water and
i clap he goes that clap is not for show
that clap is you wet your hand and you
clap and that removes all the moisture
that like kind of like splashes the
moisture off your hands so you just just
enough so that when you touch the right
it's not going to stick to your hand and
so i was like oh [__] and then he kind
of showed me how to do the first one or
whatever and so that was kind of like my
first experience was feeding him and
like that same day
if you ever watch lost the guy hugo from
lost uh came in and he ordered food or
whatever it's crazy anyway so that's
that's part of how that story ended have
you heard of um i want to talk about
intensity and billy of the week because
i came across this guy that is
incredibly fascinating and one of the
most intense people i've ever read about
have you ever heard of michael rubin
michael rubin is that the fanatics guy
yes so he's interesting because he's a
young guy he's probably not yet 50 but
if he is 50 he's early 50s and his
name's michael rubin he's been a baller
for years and years and years and so
this guy is incredibly fascinating but
not a lot of people know who he is i
think he's worth like 10 billion dollars
like you know he's worth a ton of money
you know like jack dorsey money and yet
he's like pretty under talked about and
so this guy listen to his story so i was
reading reading about him so basically
he's in the news now but i'm going to
explain his background so at the age of
12 he started uh a ski tuning bit shop
in his in his parents basement and then
two years later at 14 he got uh 2 500 in
bar mitzvah gifts and he leased a uh an
office or a shop near his parents house
and by age 16 he was already in 120 000
in debt and had to settle with creditors
and his dad had a uh pay him
give him
bail him out for thirty seven thousand
dollars and he was basically said like
i'll bail you out but you have to go to
college and you gotta stop this nonsense
so he goes to college but then after a
couple of semester he drops out and he
already has five new ski shops and it
kind of kicks ass and he eventually
sells it and then at the age of 21
he starts his business called kpr sports
it's an equi an equipment closeout
company by age 21 it has a million
dollars in sales two years later age 23
50 million dollars in sales at the age
of 20 uh at 23 in 1995 he purged it
purchased 40 of the uh women's shoe
company reika javier de breca who was
around in like the 90s and early 2000s
and then eventually he started this
company called gsi commerce he kind of
pivoted into this thing where it was
called gsa gsi commerce and they would
buy brands and they would kind of be the
logistics and back end that make these
brands amazing and he sold that at uh
age like 28 for 2.4 billion dollars
netting him 150 million dollars
personally then a few years later he
bought the business back and he formed
three different companies the first was
shoprunner have you heard of shoprunner
no
shoprunner basically was kind of like
amazon prime but for all non-amazon
stores so you could spend 100 and get
free shipping on loads of different
stores he started rue la la which you
probably wouldn't have heard of but i
bet your wife has and then he has and
then he started fanatics he sold
shoprunner recently for 228 million
dollars fanatics ends up becoming this
massive business and so basically if you
buy like a rams jersey um it's made by
fanatics and they basically work with
the nfl they're like the official
merchandiser basically of like all major
sports but here's where [__] gets really
really wild so fanatics turns it now at
this point i believe it's three
different large businesses so there's
the main fanatics business which is they
basically have licenses with nfl mba mlb
they make shirts and stuff like that and
and just normal merchandise i think i
believe if it's not publicly traded it's
nearly publicly traded and worth 18
billion dollars the second thing that he
did was he spun out this trading card
division have you seen that there's just
no news
it's called fanatics trading cards and
so basically he raised 350 million
dollars at a 10.4 billion billion
valuation and so basically there's
companies like tops everyone knows tops
they make cards i think they also make a
bunch of other stuff like gum and random
things but tops plus the other three big
dogs in the space i forget what they are
but if you're listening into the
baseball cards
huge
so collectively those make like two
billion dollars a year in ebitda like so
it's a fairly big business and so you're
like 10 billion dollar trading card
company it is pretty frothy but like it
could if it you know
can be a billion dollar a year in profit
business totally and so he raised money
for that and then he has the second
thing called candy digital which is
making nfts for sports and they just
raised 100 million dollars at 1.5
billion evaluation and so he spun all of
these off and now he's also the owner of
the 76ers and the new jersey devils the
sports team
pretty freaking wild and if you follow
him on instagram which i just started
following him he's homies with meek mill
uh and he like helped get him out of
prison and he's uh spends a lot of his
time michael rubin spends a lot of his
time with prison reform incredib
incredibly prolific very very very
confident very fast moving very intense
incredibly interesting guy seems like a
good guy um
for for him to come on the pod this guy
this guy's cool i've seen a lot of his
interviews
and uh and i like him a lot and i think
what he did with fanatics is like
i always view doing things in sports
it's like if you want to do sports and
music it's like actually so hard to win
because
it's like oh yeah i'm passionate about
sports great you and you know 2.2
billion other people and so it's really
really hard to do what i'll call obvious
ideas in sports like yeah selling the
merch selling jerseys selling shirts
so for him to build such a large
business in what would be such a
competitive
space is really impressive to me
it's very impressive and what i when i
was watching interviews with them so
gary vee is a partner on this um on a
couple of his things like i don't know
if he's an investor or if he gets a
small stake i don't know what how the
how the thing is but he's he's mentioned
a lot of the articles as like either a
co-founder or a founding team member
something like that and basically i've
hung out with gary maybe only three or
four times including the time we had him
on the podcast i've hung out with him in
person and he has the same energy that
i've noticed michael rubin has where
there's basically like this thing that i
have and i think every human being even
these guys they just don't have a lot of
it where it's like a self-limiting
belief where it's like well
you know i can't do this because of this
this and this and i've noticed with gary
he's talk like one time he told me he's
like i wanna my next thing he's like i'm
going to create all these restaurants
and they're actually going to be
completely free and the way they're
going to make money is amex or whoever
is going to sponsor it um like he was
just brainstorming he's like but i'm
going to do that and in my head i'm like
well that's really dumb i mean a free
restaurant that's the stupidest thing
i've ever heard of um
but
i feel like nine out of 10 things he
does i would say that's a really dumb
idea and they work and you know he said
he's gonna come out with these what's
his nft thing it's uh
v friends like if he told me i'm like
gary this is really dumb or uh you know
like that's not gonna work and it's been
incredibly lucrative and very successful
and they don't have this limiting belief
where it's like this won't work for this
reason or this reason it was just like
well why not like it logically it makes
sense i think this can work anyways this
is very uh timely so let me tell you why
by the way i've noticed a lot of these
coincidences happening in my life where
i'm thinking about something where i'm
doing something and then somebody who's
like
uh like-minded they're almost
experiencing the same thing just in a
different way we trade these stories so
same exact thing all right so i told you
i'm reading think and grow rich there's
a section in there that i remember you
know it's just like stuck in my head and
he goes
to be successful one needs to be success
conscious and i was like i don't even
know what that means i don't think most
people know that means but the
interesting part is the second line
that's what he says after that he goes
he goes and people who fail all fail for
the same reason
they take their current limitations as
real limitations right they take the
perceived limitations that are that
they're pursuing they're feeling now
and they treat them as real
and what you're saying is exactly that
which is that everybody yeah oh i need
to do this but i don't have the time but
i don't have the money but i don't have
the experience but this person said they
would get back to me and they haven't
gone back to me yet uh but this but you
know the port is closed right now and so
the shipment's going to be delayed it's
like there's always these limitations
that feel very real in the moment and
what what successful people do really
really well is they sort of just ignore
all those limitations they ignore all
the limitations about themselves and
even the thing when somebody says no to
them they're like okay cool like what
does your boss think about that how
about i talk to them let me see what
they have to say how about i go to your
competitor let me see what they have to
say how about i ask you again but this
time i'm gonna ask more playfully and
later on at night out over a glass of
wine now you're gonna have a different
answer and like they don't take no for
an answer on any front uh you know on
their own limitations from they don't
take no from themselves and they also
don't take no from the world and um so i
noticed that so i yesterday we were
finishing up our workout
and uh and we have a kind of like you
know like it's we trained the body but
we trained the mind at the same at the
same time and so we were talking about
this i said man i read this great thing
and i know i could share it with him
because he's he's the type too that like
to eat this stuff up and he goes oh
that's great and i go but you know what
i don't want to just sit here and say
that's great because what what it really
means when i say this and we're like
yeah yeah yeah that that's true is we
kind of do this thing where we're like
yeah that's true
uh other people [__] that up but you
know not me yeah um there's like this
inherent like yeah other people really
need to get this but they don't get it i
get it so i said no no screw that just
like we just did reps in the gym on our
you know shoulders and and lats and
whatever else i said let's get a rep
right here
i say what's a let's get a rep right now
what's something that you want that you
just have some random limitations that
you it's not even like you haven't been
able to overcome it
honestly you're just not even aware of
it you're not even like saying it out
loud once you say it out loud you'd
probably find a solution to it but you
don't really do it i said i'll go first
i said man ever since i went worked out
at sam's gym i want my garage gym to
feel like that i already had the weights
i'm already doing the workout but it
doesn't feel the same his gym feels
amazing to be in he's got the floor
finished properly he's got this he's got
the fan on the wall he's got the music
system it just feels great i want my gym
to feel like that and i said i want that
and what's my limitation i hired this
one contractor he's been really slow
getting back to me with a quote
it's like well i could think of 10 ways
to solve that problem right now but like
i just kind of hadn't put my awareness
on what was what was a random limitation
that was standing in the way of me and
something i wanted and i told my trainer
so you got to do one now what's what's
something you want that you have a
limitation i said let's get a rep and
this is a very powerful way of thinking
which is when you get advice
don't just be like yeah advice let me
write that quote down let me tweet that
quote out it's like no no
apply it in the moment get a get a rep
doing the thing and so uh so let me ask
you let's do it live
what's the thing you want
in your life and then what's the thing
you want that you're not kind of like
it's not being realized fully right now
it could be anything could be something
your relationship work-wise money-wise
fitness-wise whatever something small
something in your house whatever um
what's the thing you want
and then try to shine that light on
what's the limiting what's something
you've just let limit you for no reason
that gary vee wouldn't that michael
rubin wouldn't
um okay this sounds silly
it should sound silly it's perfect
because it's usually the silly things
i've had a fear of camping for a long
time and i want to spend more time in
the wilderness because i like the idea
of it but like i'm kind of afraid of
like being out at night time in the
woods by myself or with like a small
group
okay great so you you want to camp and
then you're afraid and then so if you
shine the light what's the what's the
limited what's the thought that goes
into your head is it i don't have x or
i'm afraid of why what is it i've just
not i've just i've not bought like uh
camping equipment i've not looked at
where to go i've not told a buddy or two
that i want to go do it and and i've not
take i've just not planned anything make
it more personal why haven't you planned
anything
uh what's called fear
fear of what fear of being out at night
in the wilderness by myself and that's
the perfect stopping point because
whenever you say the fear out loud it
sounds really [__] stupid it's like
i'm afraid of being outside at night by
myself like first of all i'm not scared
i'm not gonna be by myself i'm gonna be
with somebody because more fun with
friends secondly like
whatever it's not that scary i could do
it uh right so like that's the best part
of like when you finally find the thing
and you say it out loud it just sort of
dissolves because it's like well that
sounds silly like
it doesn't have it doesn't have as much
power once i say it out loud once i
shine the light on it's like scurries
away
well you got to get your gym set up then
it's not that hard i sent you the link i
know yeah i have everything the
the limiting thing was i don't know how
to do home improvement projects like i'm
not handy dude do you know how to cut
like a slice of bread that's all you
have to do when you lay down floor you
just kind of look even easier than that
i was like i could pay this guy to do it
okay that'll solve my problem oh that
guy's not responding okay
and then i just let it fizzle there it's
like what no i want this
i want this why would i why would i just
let this wait and we we all agreed that
the one common demand
in most of the things you want is you've
come up with an excuse to wait
um like i'll give you another example i
hope he doesn't mind me saying this but
i had this guy who kind of was like an
apprentice for me for a few months and i
basically was like he was like hey i
want to learn about content and stuff
like that i said cool you come help me
research and write stuff and i'll teach
you some things and after a few months
uh he went on his way and was like
cool go out there in the world and since
then he i think i could say his name so
this guy is this guy chris i don't even
know how you say his last name chris has
look i don't know it's crazy last name
redhead guy who works at goldman red hat
guy exactly so he was a college student
at the time so when i was talking i was
a student at yale
and uh it's nice guys i've talked to him
super nice guy after he did the
apprenticeship he grew his twitter
following
from i think like 2 000 followers he
just hit a hundred thousand followers
yesterday or two days ago and he texted
me he's like dude i hit a hundred
thousand like thank you you know i
learned a bunch of stuff you showed me
kind of like what good writing looks
like and i was like dude that's honestly
it's [__] amazing like you're a
college kid and you did that like that's
that's super impressive
um
and he's like you know but i'm thinking
about like where do i go from here
i said well it's real simple like what
do you want like i'm not i'm not going
to tell you what to do next like what do
you want to do next and then go do that
thing it's really that simple
and he's like oh you know i want to
start a company
and i said okay cool so did you take
that banking job that i was telling you
not to take he's like yeah you know i've
been here for a little bit i don't think
that might that might not be the long
thing long-term thing for me i think i
want to start a company someday
i said oh you're waiting he's like yeah
i've just you know like i said okay why
don't you just quit your job and go do
that
he's like well you know and he gave me
another reason for waiting i said okay
so why don't you just go do it and he
goes well i you know if i did do it i'd
want to do it with my friend he's really
really smart super smart guy but he has
to wait a year because he's graduating
he's not graduated yet so you know i
thought i'd just wait you know a year
i said wait a year huh 10 of your 20s
you're just gonna give away wow
with precious asset just pissing it away
huh uh just waiting huh wait wow and i
was just like and he's like yeah you
know and then also you know i wanna i'm
making good money right now i wanna save
up so i have enough runway you know
money money is always like you know it
it does matter at the end of the day
i said how about this
how about instead of telling me a bunch
of reasons why you're not going to do
the thing you want to do you just start
telling me some reasons you are going to
do the thing you're going to you want to
do try that it works much better trust
me and i was like kind of a dick about
it but
it's really that [__] simple and i
notice and it's not just him ever i know
this because i do this i'm guilty of
waiting for [__] or coming up with
reasons to wait and so whoever's
listening to this that needs to hear
this
don't wait
my trainer says wait wait wait is a
weight on your back and stop waiting
so uh i had a friend who and and we
could move on after this but i don't
know if people i think people will like
this but i had a friend who on
i do this all the time so if i have
friends or people who i care about in on
april 5th
i'm at the point where i've saved enough
money to move forward with the
prototyping process i feel like i found
the right engineer to partner with it's
a decent amount of money but i think i
could do it i want to know what your
thoughts are on how to launch this i
text it back i go uh if i was you i
would do this this and this right this
morning i s i texted him this was april
5th i texted him today how'd the idea
turn out he said too expensive for me to
commit my life savings the cost and
manufacturing and marketing of a
physical product were way big and much
bigger compared to starting a software
or internet company
oh wow so you started a software company
lol no i love it i was about to say i'm
figuring out what to do and what i'm
going to stop being a worker be and then
i'll probably um
i can't say i'll probably quit after
blank ipos right don't even know what
city i'll be in next year and
it's never gonna happen it's never gonna
it will never happen no no it will never
let's imagine lovingly for this guy it
is gonna happen it's gonna happen once
he stops thinking that way right once he
stops being that way once he changes
that'll change and so i or she i don't
know i don't know what it is but
basically yeah there's a um
there's a funny thing with that and
you know i i i always wonder like do you
be a dick or do you kind of like
empathize
if you care you be a dick
and why is that
if you care well like look it's like
look do you want this or not and and
often times i say to people i'm like do
you really want this i don't know if you
actually want this and i think that you
just think it's cool to want this and i
don't think it's cool to want to you
want to either do or you don't right you
want to talk about like if you just want
to talk about it just tell me you just
want to brainstorm right or you just
want to shoot the [__] but if you're
telling me that you want this then i'll
i'll hold you accountable actually i'll
i'll say why haven't you done this right
my trainer
he goes uh he goes you know i treat
people the way they told me they want to
be
so you want to be fit right so then if
you're going to complain about doing
these sets well the guy who's fit does
this so i'm going to treat you from the
place you told me you want to be and hey
you at any given time you can come and
say i don't want it anymore i change my
mind i want this instead cool
i'm happy to change my tree i'm happy to
treat you differently when you tell me
that you have changed your mind that you
don't want to you don't want this
anymore you want something else you are
totally in the right to there but
let's be clear i'm always going to ask
you did you change what you wanted
because if you still want that thing
then i'm going to keep treating you like
the person who gets that thing
and that person doesn't do or say these
things and so i'm not going to entertain
it i'm not going to be the shoulder to
cry on i'm not going to be the one who
sympathizes and pats you on the head and
says i understand why it's tough for you
why it's so hard because it's not so
hard for that guy and so be that guy
people uh people dm us a lot of
interesting ideas my reply to all of
them they go what do you think about
this i always reply with two things i
think that's an amazing idea
and i always say it's an amazing idea uh
and then i say when are you launching
yeah it's always great amazing like
you're just asking for permit you're
just asking for permission so i'm gonna
give you permission amazing there's no
reason why this can't work oftentimes
there's a lot of reasons it doesn't
matter when are you launching right and
uh i do this mine says
sounds cool right they say
i have this idea what do you think i
would love to hear your feedback your
thoughts happen to jump on a call
i don't even reply to any of that i just
say sounds cool let me know when you
launch it so i can check it out
i always say the same thing and
sometimes i i'll reply months later like
i'll save certain conversations and i
reply do you want to talk about one more
interesting thing on the list i have one
thing from this de beers thing i've just
yeah i've been dying to hear it okay so
okay so let me tell you this story this
kind of blew my mind i got to open up my
notes for this because i i did you know
proper proper research for this um
so why don't you put your notes in this
document so i can see that it's just
really long it's like two pages of notes
so i didn't want to blow it up for this
but uh let me just tell you this story i
got your full and undivided attention
you can't even read the thing you gotta
listen to me say it all right so
somebody in my family is uh was thinking
about getting engaged soon so the whole
like engagement ring process was going
on and they were asking like you know
all the questions you have because you
don't usually you don't most people
don't buy a ton of diamond rings or
something like that so they're kind of
like you know what's the budget uh you
know that i see there's these four c's
cut clarity you know which one should i
care more about uh blah blah blah so
and and then they did this thing they
went to a jewelry shop and they tried
some i said just go try some on see what
you see what you what you like
and uh so you're not gonna buy it from
there but go to a nice shop to try
things on so you can see what shape you
like what color you like what different
prices will get you that sort of thing
and they go and they came back they said
hey you ever heard about this lab grown
diamond thing and uh have you heard of
this
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah basically they're
i mean that's all it is it's
diamonds grown in the lab right so just
the way that like now you have um you
know
for many different types of products for
meat they're trying lab-grown meats so
what if instead of farming animals and
killing them and you know contributing
to a lot of you know global warming you
could just take a stem cell from a cow
shoulder and grow a filet mignon right
that's the promise and there's a company
called memphis meats that's doing it
and it takes it looks identical to the
meat to a steak it tastes identical
because it is identical cellularly
molecularly it is identical to a normal
steak now the problem right now for meat
is that it costs like ten thousand
dollars a pound or something crazy so
you know it's not economically feasible
yet
and um and then there's this company i
was looking at potentially investing
it's called vitro labs and they're doing
this with leather they're saying hey
instead of killing animals for leather
what if we could have a cruelty-free
leather let's just grow the skin in a
lab and they're signing deals with you
know
big name luxury brands you know they're
the sort of who's who luxury brands that
they want to offer a vegan product but
they don't want to sacrifice the quality
of the material so they said hey let's
get you an identical material
molecularly matching material for that
okay so i've been interested in this
lab-grown trend and diamonds was the
latest one so i said oh interesting
diamond it's not the new it's not new
it's actually much more commercially
forward it's like out there and people
buy this stuff it's growing in
popularity compared to meats and leather
which are kind of like still in
development
so
um so i started looking into it i was
like i was like is this kind of like
[__] or what's going on and here's
what i found
the diamond industry itself is mostly
[__] and a lot of people know this
but i dug into some of the history
here's what here's what i found that
kind of interests me
so
before 1870 like diamonds uh weren't
even like
they were not even a a a considered rare
so i'm sorry plentiful sorry before 1870
they were rare because we didn't know
where to find them so like you know the
maharaja in india would would have it in
his crown or you know some egyptian
person would have it in their in their
garment but it was it was so rare that
you didn't even see it around it wasn't
even a thing it wasn't even businesses
around it but then in 1870 they find
this huge deposit in um i think south
africa and so now diamonds become this
like they realize oh diamonds are
actually not in short supply there's
tons of diamonds they found this huge
thing and so all these miners go in like
a gold rush basically and they start
mine they start establishing diamond
mines in south africa and then like six
months later a year later they all
realize like [__]
there's now too much supply we're
flooding the market with this stuff and
it's we're all going out of business
nobody can afford um nobody can afford
to to run the mine because we're we're
flooding so much supply so the miners
but no so the miner's like damn it if
everybody else just stopped i could make
a bunch of money but it's like the
prisoner's dilemma nobody wants to be
the one that stops so they all keep
going and they all put each other out of
business and so there's this guy cecil
rhodes that comes around and cecil
rhodes starts buying up the mines he's
like i need to aggregate all this supply
in south africa so he starts aggregating
it all and basically buys mines from one
of the farms is called something
something that the brothers were called
de beers that was their last name so it
becomes the de beers like mining and
exploration group or something like that
some name like that so that's where de
beers the diamond company comes from and
so de beers became this over the next
hundred years de beers becomes this
monopoly they control ninety percent of
the supply and the reason diamonds are
considered rare is because de beers owns
all the supply and they just limit how
much they produce from the mines they
could produce 10 times more but instead
they intentionally restrict supply at
the mining level
then they this is so monopolistic as
crazy so then they created this group of
200 people only 200 people were allowed
to buy from them called site holders and
they said oh you were invited so so we
control all the supply so we decide who
we sell to and we only are going to sell
these 200 and then you can go sell to
merchants now we're going to so they
could kind of hold these 200 people
accountable and say hey why is this
person over here selling at this low
price cut them off and like just cut you
off and if a new mine popped up they
would go like the mafia and they'll go
into sort of like through violence
intimidation or like even just like
market tactics they would basically like
put the mine out of business and take it
over so like let's say you discovered a
mine that had a bunch of yellow diamonds
they would flood the market with yellow
diamond supply crush your economics
you'd go out of business and they'd take
over your mind
and so they would just find whatever you
produce and they would just flood you
and so um so
all the way up until about the year 2000
they owned 90 of this thing
but
i was like i was like why is this so if
it's not rare where does the value come
from and so the story is basically
diamond mining wasn't big business right
away it was looking at okay business
good business
and then it started to like kind of like
plateau and p it wasn't really growing
that fast so in 1936 they say we got to
do something we got all this diamond
production but where there's not enough
demand now for the diamond production so
they go down madison avenue and they
find this ad agency and they find this
one guy so everybody who loves diamonds
today and every girl is demanding a
diamond engagement ring it's because of
this guy george locke back in the day
and they hire this guy and they say look
we need you to create demand for
diamonds and at that time before 1936
people were not even giving diamonds as
an engagement ring it wasn't even like
rings weren't even an engagement process
it was like very rare that people would
do that most people just kind of did an
engagement as sort of a different sort
of agreement
and so he does a big study and he says
okay look um what we need to do is this
we need to get men to buy the diamonds
for women
and we need the women to believe that
diamonds are the way that your man can
show you so for women it's like if you
want the man to say he loves you we need
diamond to represent love
diamond equals love that's like one side
of the board they said on the other side
men
the bigger the better the more expensive
the diamond the more of a man you are so
it became diamonds and they came out
worth it and it was it was like some
like ridiculously obvious statement that
they came out with right so they had a
bunch so they've done like um uh
diamonds are forever is was named i
think one of the most uh i think was
named the marketing slogan of the
century or something like that of the
last hundred years it was voted that
diamonds are forever was the best
marketing hook created because it
created this like demand for diamonds so
why is that so so there's a bunch of
like aspects to this so first how did
they build demand well it was basically
in old school influencer marketing so
they decided all right we're gonna make
diamonds look like the gift of love
and so they went to hollywood and they
went to all the producers and they said
we will give you producers here's a
beautiful diamond for you to give your
wife here's a diamond for you for your
for you on your bracelet or your
necklace your earrings or whatever and
they basically said hey
um
we will give you these diamonds for free
producer but you need to have a scene in
your movie the climax of your movie
where the man professes his love for the
woman he needs to open up a box with a
diamond ring inside and then she needs
to have an amazing reaction like she
needs to be won over because the guy did
that and so they went to all these movie
producers and the movies now all have
these scenes and you could go back and
watch this montage of before this nobody
was doing this in movies all of a sudden
every movie this was the key scene the
guy pronounces his love for his w for
the woman and gives her a diamond and
she says oh my god i love you too it
kisses him back and so they like used
that kind of inception then they went to
fashion designers and i said hey
wouldn't it be a shame if um if if if
you didn't say that the trend next year
the big trend is that diamonds are in
would let's call it the trend to
diamonds so they created this thing
called the trend to diamonds and they
just got all these fashion designers to
ambiguously say there's a trend to
diamonds so now you have the the high
art people saying this and then you have
hollywood showing it and that was like
the main sort of brainwashing mechanism
of of the world at the time no social
media no nothing
and so then they said so then you know
the ad agency starts getting uh you know
clever they're like all right
um
how do we make the diamond proportionate
to the man's success what if it was you
have to spend one month's salary on this
and they went with one month salary and
then they upped it to two months salary
and then they had an advertising
campaign that said um
how do you make two months of salary
last forever
buy a dime oh man
amazing right
and then and then they were like okay
look but hey we all know that diamonds
are actually not that rare right so we
can't have people reselling these so
they said oh uh first of all if you make
it the the the ultimate gift of love the
woman won't want to sell it the guy
won't want to sell it and then even if
they do here's what we'll do dealers the
you the merchants who sell this you
cannot take diamonds back because
diamonds even though they are like seen
in the world as like a store of value
it's like oh just jewelry it's like you
know jewelry is kind of like a safe way
to store your wealth it's like a car if
you take a diamond out of the shop it's
lost 50 of its resale value and the
dealer doesn't want you to know that so
they won't even make you an offer to buy
it back so they banned merchants from
like making offers to buy it back
because they didn't want the merchant to
tell the customer hey once you buy this
thing it's worth half uh and so they
said don't even make an offer
and um
and so they kind of like killed the
resale market and then they created this
diamonds are forever campaign so that
you would not want to sell your diamond
and they did this country by country so
like you can look in any country you can
see this chart so it's like the u.s goes
to this curve where no one's buying
diamonds that like 75 percent of
engagements are all through diamonds and
then uh 90 it gets to like 90 something
percent our engagements are done through
diamonds
in japan they they're like oh we have no
market share in japan they go they do
the same marketing playbook there it
goes from five percent of brides have a
ring to 60 and 20 year in a 20-year
period and de beers own 70 of that
market share right and then they started
creating other marketing gimmicks like
the right hand ring it's like if you're
an independent woman
you know you don't want this ring on
your left hand that shows that you're
kind of owned by this man wear a
right-hand ring
you need a diamond on your right hand
that says that's the right hand ring the
25th anniversary ring the upgrade ring
like you know just show that you're
doing better than you were before and so
they created all this like they
literally [__] created the demand and
they restricted the supply it's kind of
unbelievable um so that's kind of like
the that's amazing the core of it
there's some other stuff like you know
there's like sort of the blood diamonds
thing which is like the bad pr around it
which is that
these diamond mines were a kind of
shitty conditions to be in um but b they
were like basically using profits from
the mine to fund like
war in the area like militia war in the
area so that was kind of like you're
basically funding conflict in a way and
so the diamond industry tried to like
after that movie blood diamond came out
they tried to like clean up their image
but then lab grown diamonds started
coming out
and um
and so the lab grow diamonds come out
it's like oh [__] so first they created
a marketing campaign that says real is
rare and they basically were like if
it's real that's what makes it rare
which is what makes it valuable so if
it's a lab-grown thing
that's nothing and they refuse to
acknowledge it they refuse to sell it
they refuse to care about it but
customers were like dude this is it's
indistinguishable from a diamond the
naked eye cannot tell what's a real
diamond like mine from the earth or made
in a lab because materially again the
composition is the same it's not like a
fake it's not like a fake diamond it's
the same material it was just grown in a
lab rather than growing in the earth and
so i always get the the shane co
commercials right and they say like you
don't want to get them from a lab from a
lab it's
it's just like every other one right
they're all exactly exactly it's not
special and so the problem is it's still
growing in popularity because they sell
for about 30 of the price so you can get
like a way bigger ring that looks
identical to a diamond ring that is made
of a diamond um but it just happened to
have been like it's like do i want my
coffee sourced from you know canada or
from philippines or from africa like
it's kind of like where is it sourced so
some people care but it's growing in
popularity so then de beers
and the diamond industry they like did
the last kind of like stone cold killer
move
for years they were like lab grown is
fake
it's [__] don't buy it and they but
it was just growing in popularity
anyways so they were like all right [__]
we gotta do something else so then they
create this
up called lightbox
and they start producing lab grown
diamonds everyone's like oh my god does
this mean that lab is legit and they're
like no no no no no
lab is for people who can't afford
diamonds so we're going to sell ours so
they undercut the price like crazy so
normally a lab grown diamond will cost
like 30 or 40 of the cost so it's like a
50 60 discount
and
but they started pricing theirs at like
a 90 discount of a real diamond just to
ruin the market value of the brand
perception of labrador diamonds and they
said this is for they said they came out
in a statement they said this is for
emotionally shallow events like a sweet
16 or like a quinceanera party buy the
buy the lab ground for that don't you
know so that this is their latest tactic
to try to like
keep up this big myth this big lie
that diamonds are this rare valuable
precious gem and it's like actually just
complete [__] this is amazing
research this is a good one this is a
very good story and
what but here's the thing where we are
uh maybe it will change is us in our 30s
we all do the same thing which is right
before we get engaged we say this is
[__] i will not stand for this i
will not pay this amount of money right
my budget i'm going to set it really low
i'm going to get a fake one or i'm going
to get a lab girl like i will not buy
into this and then you get into it and
you say [__] it's going to make her
gonna make her happy yeah
and we all refuse to buy into it and
well more and more people are starting
to to go the other way
um but
but yeah it's it's amazing that this is
still the majority right given now that
lab grown is visibly identical and you
can get a way better better looking
diamond for cheaper price uh it's
amazing that that like the re the
utility doesn't overwhelm but like the
branding is that embedded it's that
strong after so long and actually
there's one other part which is that
eventually you know the diamonds do um
the the beers did lose their monopoly i
should say so like in the year 2000 they
basically broke up the monopoly because
they're getting a lot of public pressure
as a monopoly
the the buyers were kind of sick of
being like constantly threatened uh by
de beers and then people found new minds
in australia and all these other places
where they couldn't like you could kind
of just in africa you can kind of like
coerce people but in australia it's a
lot harder to like go coerce some a
minor in public to like just [__]
give you their mind and so um and so
they've changed their business strategy
so and the last factor by the way is
there's this guy the family that kind of
like created the real monopoly is the
oppenheimer family
and they've run this thing for years
first guy oppenheimer are they
they're they're very wealthy so the
business i think is like a 10 billion
dollar business i think they sold half
the stake for four or five billion uh
recently
and i also think they own like 50 of
louis vuitton or something like that
they own some other stuff too
but um
but anyways they couldn't the the in the
family there's no one to take it over
anymore uh no one wants to run the
business nobody another young generation
they didn't want they don't want their
business there's nobody there's no air
and so they're like [__] there's no air
business is still good but it's getting
harder and we don't have somebody to
fight it and so they actually switched
strategy so they broke up the monopoly
and now they shifted from like 90 market
share to 30
uh and then they started rolling out
their own retail stores and profits have
gone up but they're kind of like their
um you know their control has gone down
their power has gone down and i would
have to if i had to bet you know i'm a
i'm a very amateur historian and so i've
read a lot of these stories if i had to
bet i would bet that
once you break up a monopoly for a
family-owned business i would argue that
the odds that the odds are that the
family are now actually going to get
richer
it seems like it's just what do you mean
well so for example standard oil this is
the same thing in the 1920s teddy
roosevelt said nope standard oil you are
the beers of america you own 80 of oil
production you can't do it anymore so
they broke it up into five or eight
different companies and some of those
companies are exxon
mobil um bp right um conoco and like
five or six other companies that you
probably know of um and it made
rockefeller get significantly richer
because he owned a small stake into each
one right and they all competed with
each other and they boost their revenue
boost their profits and they all made
and he made significantly more money
because of that and that was a the big
source of his wealth was when they broke
up the company and i would say that if
facebook and instagram had to compete
with each other um it would actually
make zuckerberg richer same with youtube
and google if they had to compete it
would probably make them better and thus
the owner's a little bit more rich
exactly i i agree that's why when people
talk about breaking up facebook it's
like well you know what this is going to
do right like they're all going to
become more valuable and the services
will become better but it does open up
more room for competition whereas when
they have a absolute stranglehold then
you know it may not be as as lucrative
and it may not be as good of a product
but it's very hard to break break in um
yeah that was great that was
well there's also like an opportunity
here right like as i learned this i was
like okay i know this is not new
but if i just sample the population
it's like on one hand you do two surveys
one survey they did was hey did you know
about lab grown blah blah blah here's
what here's like look you can't tell the
difference look it's made of it's
actually the same material composite
it's the same material as diamond it's
just grown from lab rather than mine in
the earth and hey you don't have to
worry about the like ethics of the
mining because it's not not mine from
the earth
70 of like millennials are like yeah i'm
totally open to that that sounds great
but then at the same time the market
share hasn't caught up yet and so i
think that even though this is not a
brand new thing
i think that people could create a
really valuable brand like i'm curious
if somebody listened to this that wants
to go and basically take an education
based approach to selling this because i
think the more you educate people the
more they wanna like the more willing
they are to buy and if you're the one
who educates them you get that first
right of refusal to sell them
sell them their first lab grown uh
diamonds and i think
i would bet that millennials won't do
this but what's the generation after
that z i believe they would and the 18
because you know they're so um
politically correct and they're very
they they they have a high [__]
detector i believe and
for me and my friends a lot of us were
like this is not the battle i'm going to
choose right i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna
you know buy my way out of this and and
we'll fight a different battle right
with them i don't i would argue that
there's a good chance that something
like that could happen i don't think it
will happen now but i think in 10 years
when the 18 year olds get in their 20s
and 30s
uh and i would bet money i i would bet
my money i think that could work as well
so i'm bullish on this too yeah that's
great um all right do we want to do it
this is a good story that
yeah we um that that this has got to be
our our youtube click that was a very
well researched and very good story good
job very much
so that's the episode we'll see let's
see if this one's a hit i think it was
kind of interesting what do you think
ben i thought it was great
um
the de beer stuff is super super
interesting um
and uh and the intensity stuff
uh
the the sushi story was great loved it
it's good of intensity you dunked on
somebody this week you said
did you really can you dunk how tall are
you
he's mormon of course he can dunk
so i'm six four
apparently it's like the basket isn't
isn't it isn't it the basketball love uh
of the like whenever all my mormon
friends they it seems like they always
are playing basketball on sunday all of
our churches have
uh basketball courts in them and so uh
even like non-mormons play basketball in
our churches a lot now are we talking
about 64. you could do windmills or
we're barely scraping the dunk through
or whatever uh
so you know like when i was younger when
i was in high school i could do like
tomahawks and and 180s and like pretty
good dunks
but you know over the pandemic i didn't
i didn't play basketball for like almost
a year and a half so i didn't know if i
still had it and
last night i just drove i was going down
the lanes actually a buddy of mine
jumped with me and i wasn't planning on
doing him like that but i was just i was
there and i had to do it i dunked on him
can you please send me a video of
something like this and i would share it
i'll tweet the evidence
i don't think you're a guy that would
lie at all but i would love to see this
i don't think that you're a guy that
would even exaggerate a little bit yeah
i would love to see this
i don't have the video of me dunking on
the guy but i sure i have video of me
dunking so i can yeah
can i send it to me i would share that
in a heartbeat i would love to brag
about that i i are you're 6'4 we've
never seen ben in real life by the way
you're 6'4
yeah last company i worked for was all
remote and uh we had a off-site we all
met each other for the first time and
everyone was blown away they were like
oh i didn't know you were so called one
like i if i was one person at the
company told me she's like you have
short energy i can't believe you're tall
wow i know i
dude i saw this really hilarious tick
tock yesterday where this girl just goes
oh i'm i go around on live streams and i
just uh give people compliments for i
call it i i go uh we love our short
kings
and she goes to tall guys streams like
normal height our taller guy streams and
she goes we yeah we stan our short king
we love our short king with kissy face
and the guys and she clipped together
their reaction and they're just they're
all like we love our show king and they
get excited they're like wait what
i'm six i'm six i'm six and a quarter
like i don't know who you call a short
king and then like and everybody gets
like super butt hurt about it right away
it like really [__] with their brain
and she goes it's hilarious just call
them like my short king
ben please send me a video of you
dunking on fools i would love that that
would make that would make my day i'll
send it to you right now sean sam how
tall are both of you
i'm six i'm six ones
yeah we're we're both uh we're both uh
of similar height and weight i think i
mean
like when when when people meet both of
us they say you guys are much bigger
than we thought and i would say that
when we're together we look
big and tall and sean you look taller
than you are i think too
oh good i don't know what that means but
i'll take it it's better than me called
a short king well i think it's because
you got big hair
that's right that's right
you know what i don't get do you do you
guys feel tall at six foot and six foot
one
no i don't know if you feel average
height right like to me that's like six
foot six
but like if you look at global averages
or even american average like the
american male height is like only five
nine right or something yeah yeah it's
like it's short you guys are super tall
which i don't know there's a disconnect
well then you're a giant i guess so yeah
by that logic no i don't i don't feel
tall i feel uh i feel thicker than the
average person that's for sure
and you are so ben uh when you dunked on
the guy did you like scream what did it
feel like i mean i've never dunked on
anyone i've only
i've dunked a volleyball once that's the
closest i ever got it was like actually
not even i could see something smaller i
mean that's pretty good that's that is
pretty good that was like in high school
uh so
wasn't great
the guy was a friend of mine i had we
had been playing some pickup at a mormon
church actually and i just won like four
games in a row and i think people like
morale is pretty low so i just played it
cool i didn't say anything i just kind
of randomly by the way i'm not being
prejudiced it's a thing that mormons
like
it's like i've always known that there
was basketball courts at the church and
it's like your church is like a
community event right you hang out there
after church
yeah we have weekday events there
sometimes especially for like youth and
like yeah people play basketball there
yeah yep
yeah so it's a thing it is a thing sam's
it's a mormon thing to go dunk on
someone politely as you did like it's
such a morning to politely
just like
and then like to drink a coke
[Laughter]
i mean i don't too right
a lot many latter-day saints many many
members of the church do drink a lot of
soda because you don't drink coffee or
tea um but i don't
yeah whenever i go to utah like i'll go
to the drive-thru at these like soda
places and they've got the best sodas
like the weirdest combinations i love it
so i'm mormon man i'm an honorary member
i hope sam are you a coach or pepsi guy
coke die coke zero all the way all day
ben coke or pepsi
i've i've actually never had either in
my entire life what oh amazing that's
amazing okay great i saw this great
reddit thread that was like brands uh if
their slogans were true like it was like
truthful brand slogans and the pepsi one
was um
is pepsi okay
it's like the thing at the restaurant
you order a coke and then they hit you
with is pepsi okay
[Laughter]
um all right that's the episode let's
see uh we gotta cut those into clips we
had a bunch of good ones
see ya
like i can rule the world i know i can
be what i want to